a day like few others in the life of the
European Parliament kicking off at its
seat in Strasbourg with a visit by the
king of Spain Philippe the sixth plenty
of press plenty of protocol plenty of
security personnel backstage seems of
regimented efficiency as chefs work hard
to meet the surge in demand for VIP
dining crg stupid Philip me more on a
puppy's distaste Johnny normal diesel
wrong what then my Tiki expect to be
served chi Kappa to do maracanã I keep
it up w fresh defeat na zdravi after una
PhillyD sulla sewer his o2 fondo yonder
cellular phone on the shockula no bird
klase is head of catering services
orchestrating everything in kitchens
that are spread far apart in Parliament
sprawling architecture yes to venetian
Montaigne minute sassy c difficile array
the timing is one position thessaly of
ass velicity remember that is suitable
unity when it was optimized front stage
the key focus of throngs of journalists
is also the speeches to Parliament by
Angela Merkel and Francois Hollande one
after the other the first such joint
event by a German and French leader
since 1989 little and met with it
because it's so rare that to the
president of heads of government appear
and this in the chamber at once and of
course everybody expects something from
the German French tandem locomotive ya
jus a particular population allies
español pasque Petula Jubilee agua del s
Pandey eres institution como le
parlement European a day in the life of
the European Parliament for sure it's
not every day but it's one savored by
many inside and outside the kitchen